hey guess what AMD is launching the 7800
XT the 7700 xt2 the most mid-range
Powerhouse gpus launching today whoa
[Music]
they have similar price points but my
thoughts are that the prices will
probably separate a little in the market
over time probably maybe sort of kind of
the biggest difference is that these
cards are configured with 12 and 16
gigabytes of vram the benchmarks show a
bigger performance Delta than I was
really expecting between these two cards
but uh you know you can get 12 gig vram
card
16GB Ram card I really think you should
get this 7800 XT even if you're a 1080p
gamer
if you're a gamer that wants to stretch
your GPU as far as possible and You're
Still rocking something like a GTX 1060.
you what are you doing don't there's so
many awesome gpus out or 2060 or
whatever this is probably your four year
GPU uh compared with the last generation
6700 XT which apparently didn't tempt
you then the 7700 XT could be a pretty
significant upgrade they've been able to
get the effective memory bandwidth up to
about two terabytes per second on the
7700 x t and about two and three
quarters gigabytes per second or
terabytes per second on the 7800 XT
terabytes not gigabytes both cards
feature the same OBS accessible media
engine which can do you know vp1 decode
h264 265 and av1 for encode and decode
with impressive performance it's really
pretty awesome that you can do this and
full OBS compatibility which I'll talk
more about in a second total board power
is an impressive 245 watts and 263 Watts
respectively with partner models that I
saw uh having somewhat higher power
usage but not exceeding 300 watts some
reviewers might say that AMD is at a
disadvantage versus say Nvidia and
nvidia's you know competing here in
terms of power efficiency you know
strictly speaking I don't really think
that that's true I mean if we're looking
at performance per unit power I think it
would also be possible to use the
adrenaline drivers and dial in an
efficiency curve rather than a
performance curve which is what they are
out of the box and be able to beat what
team green is doing the only real win
where Nvidia could probably post some
impressive gains is via dlss 3.0 and
frame generation if you take that into
account with the efficiency it's like
I've done this many frames or this many
watts with frame generation that kind of
sorta but amd's got fsr3 their own frame
generation technology which is a little
bit more open
I think this is going to be something
that I have to visit in a future video I
do think that nearly all Gamers just
don't actually care about
the power usage of the GPU if it's less
than say 500 watts
uh the vocal minority among you you have
been seen and you have been acknowledged
but the vast majority of Gamers 500
watts and less you don't have to have a
special power supply etc etc I just
don't think you care this is the perfect
card to put in a fractal Terra the
reference version of the 700 800 XT look
at this it's so cute it's so petite it
comes in this little tiny box yeah now
go figure that ASRock and Sapphire and
XFX they've got a lot of experience
building fast quiet cards
but AMD knows their Hardware now the
partner models they're going to be a
little physically larger but they're
also going to be a lot quieter and
cooler generally these gpus are all
going to support DisplayPort 2.1 but
that can vary depending on the partner
model sometimes they can save a few
bucks on the board bomb cost to go with
DisplayPort 1.4 compatibility don't
really see DisplayPort 1.4 limited cards
as a downside now let's talk performance
of the 7800 XT and the 7700 XT testing
everything basically went according to
plan the direct comparisons are the 4060
TI versus the 7700 XT and for the 470
versus the 7800 XT but I included the
4080 tough from Asus in my comparisons
because I'm a crazy person so if you're
thinking about a 4060 TI or 4070 don't
because these guards are generally
better 10 to 25 percent faster than the
4060 TI for the 7700 XT and you know 10
15 faster it depends the performance
actually here is really good
all right first up
for this card for 4K gaming it's
actually not
it's surprisingly good like I wasn't
expecting to include 4K benchmarks or
the 7800 but it is actually pretty
decent I think long term thinking about
next gen the next next-gen AAA titles ah
or case you're probably going to be
pushing it but for older titles 4K Ultra
preset on Borderlands 3 I mean that's an
older game
being able to stay above 60 FPS even for
our 0.1 percent lows genuinely that's
very impressive 7700 XT Falls a little
behind at about 59 FPS average dipping
into the you know the low 50s but still
that's pretty impressive performance if
you're willing to sacrifice the ultra
preset or you're going to run you know
the Radeon upscaling technology then
it's not going to be an issue for you to
get a higher frame rate
for Borderlands 3 at 1080p
181 FPS how does that sound versus 163
this is one of the few benchmarks where
they're you know the 1700 XT and the
7700 XT are pretty close we'll talk a
little bit more about hyper RX but hyper
RX can bring up our 0.1 lows
considerably and keep us to an average
uh closer to or even above 181 FPS
the Callisto protocol a newer AAA title
at 4K the high preset with no FSR 113
FPS on the 7800 XT and 94 FPS on the
7700 XT at 4K modern AAA title has been
out for a little bit it's got some
optimizations not bad 1080p 213 FPS
versus 189 again at those 1080p
resolutions these cars are closer
together than you would think Callisto
protocol is also pretty close at 1440p
173 versus 160. uh you know what 4K and
1440 wide 3440 by 1440 the extra
textured memory of the 7800 XT can help
significantly I think this is one of
those titles where you can get a wider
Gap than 160 versus 173 but still this
performance is about what I expected for
cyberpunk 2077 on the 4K High preset
yeah you can do 79 FPS average with the
7800 XT
for the 1080p preset we're talking about
193 FPS at 1080p High
or 1440p high 143 FPS just for the sake
of completeness we've got our fire
strike breakdown of the 1700 XT and the
7700 XT the performance falls about
where I'd expect you can also use this
as a comparison for the 4060 TI and the
4070 and see that these cards fall well
ahead of of uh of those cards from from
Nvidia I mean you'll get the 4080 tough
gaming here which is a much more
expensive card uh 47 000 versus 53 000
and our fire strike scores
not really a lot of practical real world
difference you can kind of see that in
our other gaming benchmarks we've also
included time spy just for the sake of
completeness this is a thing you can run
just to make sure that your system is
performing about where it should or
better in the case that drivers improve
or or whatever else
shadow of the Tomb Raider is at 98 FPS
average and 78 FPS average between the 7
800 and the 7700 very respectable nadp
is 245 versus 222. again the the 7800 XT
is really not super busy at 1080p you're
not giving it a lot to do at 1080p even
on the highest presets even on more
modern AAA games other than shadow of
the Tomb Raider 1440p that's kind of in
between 178 versus 153
but overall not too bad
these cards have got the goods in terms
of being
amazing performance at given the
landscape of all the other cars you can
buy pretty good price now whether your
team green or or team blue or team red
you know the ray tracing performance at
this class of gpus
is just not there so Ray tracing at this
price class yeah
yeah and as we do this testing and we
settle into thinking about modern AAA
titles and how much vram they will use
at high and ultra settings generally I'm
seeing 10 to 15 gigabytes of vram used
at 1440p and given that these gpus clock
in at 12 and 16 gigabytes of vram I
think that's looking pretty good for a
three four five year lifespan GPU this
is you know poised to become that 1060
replacement
which is nice in a software stack the
biggest thing is that open broadcaster
OBS is finally a first class citizen
with AMD Hardware encoding and now av1
which is actually supported for YouTube
streaming and pretty sure twitch I think
actually some twitch Partners have
access to this uh av1 stuff but I could
be wrong and again more of this is going
to follow in the future rdna3 has
finally attained a high level of Polish
and cohesion here and I'm sure that this
is welcome news for gamers and streamers
alike
for Creator workflows Puget bench and
Puget bench has some pretty impressive
scores here the RTX 4070 and Premiere
Pro and DaVinci Resolve I mean the
overall scores of 95 52 and 2955
respectively between the premiere
version and The DaVinci version it's
pretty good amd's pulling ahead of
Nvidia here for Creator workloads AI is
also really hot and we can sneak in some
stable diffusion benchmarks here as well
listen AI is hot really hot as in how
it's going to make your GPU
you know you can download node.ai which
is a build of stable diffusion with web
UI kind of similar to what I did with
the Danny DeVito nightmare fuel video
which you should definitely check out if
you haven't seen it and so you can run
stable diffusion on AMD gpus with rock M
and the suite there it's like automatic
111 on the RTX 4070 versus the 7800 XT
and guess what the 7800 XT actually
pulls ahead by about 15 percent Giver
give or take Pi torch and rockim
integration is better than it's ever
been but it's even better on higher end
AMD gpus amdu is moving a Breakneck Pace
here but they've still got a little bit
more work to go on the AI side but if
you want to download and play with
stable diffusion check out node.ai and
the the AMD branch of that oh
I've got a fever
and the only prescription is hyper RX
with apologies to Christopher Walken
going forward hyper RX it's going to be
a bigger deal than I thought it's a
single click to tune supported titles
for Boost anti-lag FSR fsr3 whenever
that comes out Radeon super resolution
whatever applies to the particular
situation that you're in
uh of course fsr3 when when that's ready
one click free performance it's hard to
incorporate that into a benchmark
because well Apples to Apples
comparisons are right out the window and
we just want to know what the raw
performance of the hardware is the
software just makes the gravy on that
even better it's just extra more gravy
if you're just gaming it should be on I
tested it extensively with shadow of the
Tomb Raider and cyberpunk 2077 with
Hyper RX on and FSR in quality mode I
could bring my frame rate to over 120
FPS in cyberpunk 2077 while improving
the input latency Beyond just the
improvement from The increased frame
rate
how does that work driver optimizations
in some settings
for competitive games like fortnite and
Apex Legends yeah those are also
supported and it's really impressive To
See amd's Vision for how hyper RX is
supposed to work coming together it's
clear that AMD is actually spending a
considerable amount of engineering
effort to improve the situation for
gamers so that they can just hit a
button and get free performance and
largely hyper RX so far is living up to
what has been promised so a little bit
more and a little bit different than
what I can show off in this review video
but if more frames are more better and
you don't want to fiddle with game
settings too much the hyper RX is
probably what you want just toggle it on
and your adrenaline drivers and you'll
be glad you did overall personally I
think AMD has knocked this one out of
the park
I mean Nvidia is kind of checked out at
this point I mean they're the dominant
player in the gaming GPU Market but
between how they've launched the 40
series how they've named things the
writing on the wall with the future how
much longer can Nvidia even really care
about you know having a gaming Focus
their focus has got to be elsewhere
because machine learning and Commercial
interests is where all the money is
uh uh gaming uh
are there any software driver issues
holding AMD back at this point for one
I'm really surprised that RDMA 3 Ray
tracing performance still lags behind
what Nvidia has been able to do with
their Hardware as far as I can tell
amd's got the goods on the hardware side
I mean look at the raw AI math and what
AMD is able to do once all of that gets
in place I mean the amd's clearly ahead
in the performance unit per dollar here
the software suite is generally pretty
mature at this point from from AMD but
there's maybe a couple small pieces
missing here now the gaming performance
though was pretty good I actually only
saw a couple of weird things at F1 2023
in the rain scene there was maybe some
barely noticeable texture glitching and
I also experienced a problem with
cyberpunk 2077 where the shadows in
cyberpunk 2077 seem to maybe enable some
translucency of the texture or the
object behind it some weird visual
artifacting like that but this issue
seemed to be related to reloading a
saved game then running a bench Mark but
without actually restarting the game so
it was very difficult to reproduce I
went over those issues with AMD and they
reported that they have fixes in the
works already for those issues which is
pretty encouraging now just to make
absolutely sure we retested F1 2023 on a
fresh install with an Nvidia card and
surprise surprise we found it was doing
the same thing with an Nvidia card yeah
it turns out this must be an F1 2023
update see we we sort of get a little
bit of an advanced warning that these
cards are coming and so we will start
testing with the gpus that we have on
hand well in the time that we started
testing when it didn't do this until the
time the cars actually showed up and we
installed the driver the game started
doing this so this is a game problem not
an AMD problem the shadow issue still
exists with cyberpunk 2077 but it's
super minor and almost completely
unnoticeable and historically the NVIDIA
drivers have had the twinkle Sparkle
problem with cyberpunk 2077 specifically
this is a tiny inconsequential nothing
Burger
subjectively my experiences with AMD
cards in general over the last year 18
months have been awesome especially for
the 7000 series although I've been using
six and seven thousand series gpus
Pretty extensively they are clearly the
best value and well supported cards in
the market today I think in case you're
wondering about Linux support it's also
pretty good check out the level 1 Linux
video coming in a day or two probably
day after tomorrow give or take on
getting these things up and running in a
Linux environment
overall good job team AMD
pretty impressive everything's coming
together if you have any problems or
weirdness or anything that you want to
report definitely check in at the level
one text forums I'm Wendell this is
level one I'm signing out you can find
me in the level one forums
[Music]
thank you